c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir l'émotion lors de la
cérémonie de restitution de la dent de
patrice lumumba seul dépouille retrouvée
depuis son assassinat en 1961 que les
pouilles qui retournera en république
démocratique du congo pour avoir enfin
une sépulture nous serons à bruxelles et
nous recevons sur ce plateau jean
jacques lumumba petit neveu de l'ancien
premier ministre assassiné interview à
suivre
le sommet des sept membres de la
communauté d'afrique de l'est au kenya
une réunion consacrée à la situation
sécuritaire dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo des membres ce
sont ses membres se sont entendus sur la
mise en place d'une force régionale nous
serons un irobi dans un instant enfin
nous évoquerons la journée mondiale des
réfugiés pour l'occasion nous irons en
afrique du sud vous verrez que les
enfants réfugiés peine à être scolarisés
reportage à suivre à la fin de ce jour
[Musique]
il aura fallu attendre soixante et un
ans pour que la le héros de
l'indépendance congolais patrice lumumba
est une inhumation la belgique a
restitué après de longues années de
procédure une dent à la république
démocratique du congo il s'agit du seul
reste de l'ancien premier ministre
violemment assassiné une dépouille rendu
lors d'une cérémonie empreinte d'émotion
notre correspondante à bruxelles alix le
bourg dans étaient présentes
l'émotion est vive aujourd'hui à
l'ambassade de la république
démocratique du congo ici à bruxelles où
la diaspora congolaise peut enfin rendre
hommage à son héros national patrice
lumumba sa dépouille a été remise
aujourd'hui par la belgique à ses
descendants plus de 60 ans après
l'assassinât du premier premier ministre
congolais juste quelques mois après
l'indépendance de la république
démocratique du congo c'est un grand
jour pour moi et pour le congo et pour
mon fils qui est pas né au congo qu'il
est en amérique que de l'emmener
aujourd'hui ici et
j'espère que la belgique et le congo ou
pourra aujourd'hui
est vraiment une famille et plus être
dans cette rancune qu'est la terre de
nos ancêtres vote du sénat sur
on nous a rendu notre dignité donc là je
peux avoir des ailes pour des devoirs
magifique angolaise des souches en 1961
le corps de patrice lumumba avait été
dissous dans de l'acide un policier
belge chargé de faire disparaître le
corps avait récupéré une dent qui ne
sera saisie par la justice que des
décennies plus tard aujourd'hui c'est
cette relique qui a été placée dans le
cercueil
pour moi ce morceau là c'est déjà
beaucoup ça a beaucoup de sens et en
tant que jeune j'ai on a juste envie de
de poursuivre en fait là où lui s'était
arrêté et lui c'est vraiment lui qui
était la base de la démocratie
la base de l'indépendance parce qu'à
partir de là d'autres pays de l'afrique
ont commencé à prendre leur indépendance
l'ambassade restera ouverte toute la
nuit pour tous ceux qui souhaitent se
recueillir devant la dépouille du
premier premier ministre congolais puis
le cercueil s'envolera demain direction
kinshasa
et jean-jacques le monde bat le petit
neveu de l'ancien premier ministre est
avec nous sur ce plateau merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'être venu de bruxelles pour
être ici sur ce plateau tout d'abord
j'ai envie de vous demander votre votre
sentiment aujourd'hui salut
j'ai ressenti par ma d'émotion guettier
d'ailleurs à la cérémonie à ce moment
j'ai ressenti pas mal d'émotions vous
savez
l'histoire du congo a été brisée a
brutalement brisé à teulat 61 ans cas
patrice et ses compagnons paulo aux kits
ont été assassinés et ça représente
beaucoup de choses pour le congo et pour
les congolais vous savez qui a vécu et
qui continue à vivre un cycle d'impunité
ya de cela plusieurs années ce soit
avant ou après les indépendances et même
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et donc c'est un
soulagement pour la famille et surtout
un soulagement pour le congo mais c'est
surtout un début d'éclaircissements sur
beaucoup de choses parce que vous savez
qu'après la justice doit être faite
et la justice et le mettre au monde de
cette nation qui est aujourd'hui en
perdition sur beaucoup de choses alors
justement qu'est ce que vous attendez de
cette justice cette danse est dépouille
d'ailleurs vous ne souhaitez pas parler
de danger exactement voir je souhaite
pas parler de dents je sais parler des
restes du corps au delà des pluies de
l'illustré disparu parce que on on sait
c'est le seul élément que la famille a
pour aujourd'hui pour faire le deuil
pour permettre à la nation qu'on laisse
de faire son deuil alors qu'est ce que
vous attendez maintenant que cette
dépouille était restitué qu'elle va être
inhumé en république démocratique du
congo sur la terre de patrice lumumba
qu'est ce que vous attendez de plus de
la justice la justice doit pouvoir
rétablir la vérité va sonner il ya eu
des personnes qui étaient impliqués
aujourd'hui c'est un secret de
polichinelle les grandes puissances les
etats-unis la belgique entre autres ont
eu des gens très impliqués dans cet
assassinat et aujourd'hui il est
question de rétablir l'histoire pour que
la mémoire non seulement de lumumba mais
de ses compagnons mais s'être rétabli et
vous savez c'est aussi important que
cette justice soit faite à l'un des
martyrs
les plus emblématiques parce que vous
savez il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
tombés qui continue à tomber en
république démocratique du congo pour
notre liberté pour notre pays il est
important d'insister tourner sur la
justice pour bâtir une vraie paix pour à
notre nation alors il ya eu quelques
archives qui ont été
déclassifiés notamment ceux des archives
aux etats-unis cette ligne tout
simplement c'est très peu
chi chi où on apprenait qu'il y avait eu
une tentative d'assassinât de patrice
lumumba par empoisonnement validée par
le président eisenhower
est ce que est ce que vous vous demandez
plus notamment aux états unis je pense
que la sayette implique je pense
qu'après 61 ans les états unis comme
toutes les autres nations et toutes les
personnes qui ont été impliquées sur
cette question doivent avoir le courage
d'affronter la vérité de dire cette
vérité aux congolais parce que ils
méritent nos combats comme tous les
congolais de avoir droit à la justice et
c'est important je crois qu après
pratiquement trois générations les
traîtres est capital que nous puissions
connaître maturité alors j'ai une
situation intéressante que je vais vous
lire celle de patrice lumumba l'histoire
dira un jour son mot mais ce ne sera pas
l'histoire qu'on enseignera à bruxelles
à washington à paris ou aux nations
unies mais celle qu'on enseignera dans
les pays a franchi du colonialisme et de
ses fantoches quelle place aujourd'hui à
patrice lumumba dans les livres
d'histoire en république démocratique du
congo très peu et je pense que là là
dans cette justice réparatrice
l'éducation pour moi aime on aime la vie
doit faire partie des priorités pour
pouvoir enseigner et en république
démocratique du congo et en belgique
parce que vous savez des jeunes belges
eux connaissent très peu l'histoire de
l'onb à la justice est là le
rétablissement de la vérité mérite
d'être fait pour que les jeunes belges
connaissent ce qui s'est fait pendant la
période de la colonisation et même après
parce que les deux pays sont intimement
liés il est très important
qu'aujourd'hui c'est cette histoire
puisse être enseignée et surtout une
histoire de vérité et non une histoire
de vainqueur
devin cloud de dominer de données est-ce
que ce que faire une place à patrice
lumumba dans les livres d'histoire
aujourd'hui c'est aussi tourné une
certaine page et avancer c'est aussi
faire connaître vous savez l'histoire la
mémoire la culture sont des valeurs qui
solidifie la force d'une nation nous
avons une nation qui a une vocation
d'être une puissance et notre histoire
elle mérite d'être enseignée d'être
reconnu alors vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure d'impunité vous avez dire encore
aujourd'hui quel est votre regard sur ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en république
démocratique du congo seulement impunité
en l'entend souvent notamment du docteur
mukwege et qui demande la justice pour
les massacres dans l'est de la rdc
caisse quel est votre regard à vous
petit neveu de patrice mon regard et et
est très triste mais vous savez je ne
peux pas me plaindre et continuer à
avoir un regard baissé c'est aussi
soutenir ce que fait entre autres de
docteurs m'ont pris gueydan dans son
combat et continue à réclamer une
justice réparatrice parce que vous savez
sur la justice la paix n'aura pas de
place et il ne faut pas faire une p
décoratives il faut faire une paix qui
va apaiser les coeurs et les esprits et
la république démocratique du congo ne
manque pas de grand homme un docteur on
croyait patrice lumumba y en aura
d'autres très probablement qui qui
seront qui seront là pour construire le
pays j'ai une dernière question assez
rapidement le roi des belges a présenté
ses excuses c'est ce que pour vous ça
suffit je pense que c'est pas suffisant
parce que nous je crois que la justice
doit dire son nom et c'est elle qui doit
apaiser réellement les esprits ce que a
fait le roi des belges est très
encourageant aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est insuffisant pour la suite merci
beaucoup jean-jacques le mamba petit
neveu de l'ancien premier ministre merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
livrer votre émotion après la
restitution de cette dépouille et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci à
vous et on va continuer à parler de la
république démocratique du congo on en
vient cette réunion de sept membres de
la communauté d'afrique de l'est à
naïrobi une réunion consacrée à la
situation sécuritaire dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo les
dirigeants se sont entretenus sur la
mise en place en temps du pardon sur la
mise en place d'une force régionale pour
tenter de mettre fin au conflit la
correspondance anaérobie bastien nous
lie il n'y avait plus vraiment de
suspense 50 à la création de cette force
est africaine après les déclarations du
président kenyan uhuru kenyatta la
semaine dernière qui appelait à sa
création et après la rencontre ce
dimanche entre les chefs d'état major
des différentes armées d'afrique de
l'est qui ont rédigé un document qui a
été rendu ce lundi aux chefs d'état de
la communauté des états d'afrique de
l'est réunis ici à nairobi pour un
sommet sur la sécurité dans l'est de la
rdc donc cette force est désormais actée
maintenant qu'elles vont être ses
mandats qu'elles vont être ses membres
est bien difficile de le savoir pour
l'instant notamment le honda va t'il
pouvoir participer puisque félix
tshisekedi le président congolais avait
dit ne pas vouloir voir de soldats
rwandais sur son sol est ce que cette
force qui doit collaborer avec la
monusco selon le président ou au kenya
tas va être une force de maintien de la
paix ou est ce qu'elle sera plus active
comme l'ont été les militaires ougandais
au cours des derniers mois pour
l'instant nous ne savons pas autre
annonce dans ce communiqué la demande
d'un cessez le feu avec les groupes
rebelles ce communiqué qui appelle donc
les groupes rebelles notamment le m23 à
déposer les armes et à rendre les
positions qui ont été capturés au cours
des dernières semaines et enfin cet
appel à surveiller son langage pour les
populations situées dans cette zone de
conflit il ne faudrait pas aggraver la
situation il ya eu des tensions on a pu
le voir au cours des dernières semaines
notamment entre kinshasa et kigali et
bien pour qu'une paix prospère et
durable puisse s'établir il faut faire
attention à ce que chacun dit et pour ne
pas attiser les tensions au cours des
prochaines semaines c'est ce que dit ce
communiqué au mali plus de 130 civils
ont été tués au cours du week end dans
trois localités voisines dans le centre
du pays lors d' attaque attribuée à des
djihadistes une annonce du gouvernement
ce lundi
le message du président ukrainien à
l'union africaine volodymyr zelensky
s'est adressé en visioconférence à ses
membres pour lui l'afrique est otage de
l'invasion russe en ukraine il a par
ailleurs assuré que des négociations
difficiles et est actuellement en cours
pour débloquer les ports ukrainiens ou
des millions de tonnes de céréales ne
peuvent actuellement être acheminés vers
l'afrique
au sénégal le principal opposant ousman
sonko restent mobilisés qu'il a appelé
la si à une nouvelle manifestation
contre le pouvoir le 29 juin une
manifestation malgré l'interdiction de
la précédente et des heurts qui avaient
fait trois morts l'opposant appellent
aussi à des concerts de casseroles à
partir de mercredi les précisions de
notre correspondante à dakar sarah sakho
devant la presse ce lundi la coalition
d'opposition y est mis à ce cas nous y a
de nouveau demandé la réhabilitation de
sa liste nationale de titulaire liste
sur laquelle figurent donc ousman sonko
elle a également exigé de nouveau la
libération de ceux qu'elle a appelé ses
otages politiques
ousman sonko le leader de la coalition a
de nouveau accusé le président macky
sall de vouloir briguer un troisième
mandat et à cette fin de chercher à
éliminer toute opposition il a ensuite
déroulé le plan d'action de sa formation
le v9 avec ou sans utilisation nous
allons organiser notre manifestation sur
le territoire national
ça c'est la première information et si
macky sall vous empêcher cette affaire
je le dis ici et je lui adresse des que
mal à le leur le message qu'ils soient
prêts à nous arrêter ou à nous liquider
tous ceux qui sont pas d'accord avec la
manière dont macky sall gère le pays
ce que nous proposons c'est des concerts
de casseroles et de klaxon à partir de
ce mercredi après demain
00 de son côté la majorité au pouvoir
fustigé un comportement qu'elle dit
irresponsable de yiwu askanwi benno boca
cas rappelle aussi que huit listes sont
en compétition pour ces législatives et
que le pays ira aux urnes normalement
vous avez aujourd'hui il ya eu à ce cas
lui qui est l'opposition radicale parce
que il faut aussi savoir que l'autre
partie de l'opposition souhaitent aller
aux élections l'ong iavi askanwi estime
que c'est par la violence par la force
que les choses doivent se faire on ne
pourrait pas comprendre qu' une seule
liste parmi les huit validé décide de
voilà de ne pas aller aux élections et
et où peut il imposer cela par la force
non c'est pas un modèle
disons que le sénégal et les sénégalais
se sont choisi depuis plusieurs
décennies la démocratie sénégalaise est
suffisamment ancrées et respecté et
cette tradition doit on doit continuer
c'est donc l'impasse politique à
quelques semaines à peine de ces
législatives et alors que la campagne
électorale n'a pas encore démarré elle
devrait se tenir à partir du 10 juillet
prochain
un appel à manifester également en
guinée pour ce jeudi le pays retient son
souffle alors que les marches sont
interdites
la principale plate forme de la société
civile le front national pour la défense
de la constitution appelle à dénoncer la
durée de la transition et exigent
l'ouverture d'un dialogue des religions
et ont tenté une médiation entre les
parties pour apaiser les tensions ce
dimanche ils ont rencontré le fn décès
la correspondance à conakry de l'amitié
quitté
les discussions ont eu lieu pendant près
de deux heures à huis clos au siège du
fn d'essayer au nom de ses pairs et les
djéliba diaby on dit des religieux bien
connu dans le pays pour ses différentes
médiations dans les crises a tenté de
convaincre les responsables du front
national pour la défense de la
constitution de sur soi à cette marche
de contestation contre les militaires au
pouvoir à des échanges ont qualifié de
franc et ouvert à par toutes les parties
pour où le religieux les manifestations
meurtrières adieu régime d'alpha condé
sont encore dans les esprits des
guinéens notre pays a tellement connu
des difficultés
nous devons privilégier le dialogue à la
place de la rue à la place des
confrontations
qui dit manifester vous savez très bien
que c'est un droit dans notre pays mais
on parle des interdictions et lorsque
manifestation est interdite vous savez
très bien le risque qui paie sans doute
du côté du front national pour la
défense de la constitution on accuse
toujours les militaires au pouvoir d'une
gestion unilatérale de la transition en
cours neuf mois après la prise du
pouvoir par le cndd jusque là nous
n'avons pas un calendrier que le cnrd
sachent qu'ils ne sont pas légaux et qui
sont légitimes et que cette légitime
qu'est
ils la doivent à nos autres concitoyens
ce qui explique d'ailleurs que nous
sortions le 23 pour prouver au cnrd qu'
il ya une partie du peuple qui n'est pas
d'accord avec eux c'est une médiation de
dernière chance pour beaucoup de
guinéens qui pas peur ont déjà commencé
à s'approvisionner en denrées
alimentaires de première nécessité
pour rappel le mouvement est fan des ces
appels j'ai dit ses partisans dans la
rue pour disent ils dénoncé la gestion
de la transition par les militaires
la 26e journée mondiale des réfugiés
filippo grandi haut commissaire des
nations unies pour les réfugiés étaient
pour l'occasion en visite à abidjan en
côte d'ivoire il a prononcé la fin du
statut de réfugiés pour les ivoiriens
ayant quitté leur pays il a également
rappelé les difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontés les pays de la région et on
va continuer à parler des réfugiés
direction à l'afrique du sud la
constitution certifie que chaque enfant
a droit à l'éducation mais la réalité
est tout autre les écoles sont
surchargés et donne donc la priorité aux
enfants sud africains les enfants de
réfugiés se retrouve très souvent
déscolarisés une ong tentent depuis
maintenant à 14 ans de pallier cette
situation en offrant des cours à ceux
qui n'ont pas cette chance reportage de
caroline but mais et stéphane carstens
c'est quand les écoliers sud-africain
rentrer à la maison que ses enfants
partent à l'école enfants de réfugiés
ils n'ont malheureusement pas accès au
système scolaire sud africain qui
surcharge et a le droit de les refuser
alors une ong vient les aider elle
s'appelle de 3 à 6 car ces deux trois
heures à 6 heures tous les après midi
que l'association profite des salles de
classe vite de ce collège pour éduquer
ceux qui ne sont pas scolarisés
[Musique]
même les enseignants sont des réfugiés
justin est diplômé en relations
internationales mais n'a jamais pu
travailler en afrique du sud elle s'est
dévouée à ce projet 3 la pièce c'est un
peu comme si on était à la maison avec
nos propres enfants
les voir progresser nous inspire
certains sont partis de la maternelle et
on fait le primaire d'autres ont déjà
fini l'université et travail
l'association fournit les uniformes le
matériel scolaire et aussi les repas
cette scolarisation est une bouffée
d'oxygène pour ces enfants qui ont bien
du mal à s'adapter magnifique est arrivé
dans le pays alors qu'elle avait dix ans
depuis son père est décédé c'est pour ça
qu'elle rêve d'être docteur
on est venue en voiture depuis le congo
c'était dur d'apprendre l'anglais
j'avais peur d'aller dans les magasins
parce que j'en parlais pas la langue et
faire les courses étaient difficiles et
quand on allait au parc les enfants du
quartier se moquer de nous parce qu'on
ne parle pas anglais
plus tard je voudrais rentrer pour y
construire un hôpital le directeur du
programme fait tout pour qu'il s'intègre
rapidement dans le système sud africain
les enfants nous font part de leurs
craintes il ne se sent pas forcément
intégré dans le pays et c'est pour ça
que nous avons les activités pour les
intégrer dans les communautés où ils
vivent
étrangement en afrique du sud quel que
soit le parti politique personne ne
défend le droit des réfugiés
ne s'opposent
plus de 200 enfants passent par ce
projet tous les ans une goutte d'eau par
rapport aux besoins des 5 millions de
réfugiés mais une goutte d'eau qui
changent la vie de ses enfants
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique restait avec nos l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]